[Music]
and bad joke news ah submitted by jakey
come to NYC we haven't been there in a
while I missed the pizza
hello guys is here but it's not this is
not the same it's not as good you got to
eat it standing up in the cold that's
what it's really good you know they have
a storefront there now oh really yeah
they no longer how the car is now start
it's no more card that's not to say that
I want to feel like a roach was in my
food though yeah this [ __ ] tastes the
same I never had Shake Shack in into New
York's what Shake Shack in New York is a
lot bigger than the one in LA la is like
this small hamburger yeah
in New York is this big I like Shake
Shack a former Playboy model was
arrested after faking her own kidnapping
as a joke as a joke
yeah well would you stress people out
like that her friend nor the victim hmm
it's just a joke yeah this woman her
name is Angelica Hart is that a real
name maybe she's related to Kevin Hart
well that's what the e at the end of
hard day Oh French hard thing yeah so
this woman she's 40 years old she used
to line up a Playboy and I guess that's
what made her gonna near that no but
anyways she faked her own kidnapping by
ordering her terrified friend to pay an
8,000 pound ransom you know that sounds
just like a failed attempt and then she
played it off as a joke because 5,000
and so she had a friend named Erin to do
to communicate with the victim so Darren
sent the victim a photo of a fake
severed finger and then they ordered her
to pay five thousand pounds if she ever
wants to see her friend again she's
asking euros what a good friend I mean
British pounds yeah well it's not
American those are the way it's being
reported
maybe she's you can't playboy or
something you have you KP boy yeah they
have a world Playboy yeah every country
apparently the photo of descent showed a
hand with the finger seemingly cut off
so it just looks like it's like this
then I don't know they were trying to
like scare the the victim into paying up
money and so finally the victim went to
the police
we've tracked everything down to this
Darren dude and then they got an address
and they showed up to that address and
they found this girl
the Playboy model they found her safe
and sound and they were like what the
[ __ ] like what's happening why did you
come to her eyes oh my god the hot bad
no they're like why would you do this
and then it was just like oh it's just
it was just a joke [ __ ] but then the
way they're reporting it they're saying
that the victim had experienced
flashbacks of a kidnapping that she had
experienced herself oh that makes sense
[ __ ] up yeah that makes sense what
she's so terrified yeah
like [ __ ] let me help my friend what if
her friend already knew about it and
then like wanted to [ __ ] with her little
Birmingham Booga I mean I have a pretty
big sense of humor but just just stuff
like these I don't understand yeah we
don't [ __ ] around with each other like
that like that's I wish we did though
you know our lives are kind of boring
like outside of the camera you know you
want to start pranking each other okay
okay think of jackass and how they can't
do [ __ ] you want that I'm just saying
TIFF wanted us to do it's kidnapping
simulation remember I didn't say I
wanted you to do it I said I'm curious
to see what that would be like don't
think I want to
you guys made my word I'm an optimist so
curiosity sounds like desire no it does
that if I go I'm curious how it feels
like to have a million dollars I'm
pretty sure it gonna give me a minute
dollar you know what though ever since
we filmed that skit where you guys did
kidnap me I was like we were waiting cuz
we know your ex many a pregnant soon
okay you can't do that to a very well
why have pz tells me everything you're
looking plated sooner you know i know
you're already married but this is
what's gonna happen okay we're gonna
kidnap you put you in a container send
you off to a remote Southeast Asian
when you show up there a group is gonna
pick you up you're gonna think you got
kidnapped by a terrorist group and in
case he's gonna pop out in a suit and
say will you remarry me and then she
wakes up in an ice bath with blood and
she does know where the Bloods from he
has a shop your head like it'll be fake
ice yeah we put tap water because your
brain is gone anyway so but don't do it
to me though I don't I just want to see
you guys it's your wish no it isn't yeah
curious no I'm not curious anymore
that curiosity left if you guys never
prank one of the guys all hell would
break loose you know that will go into
our save get our guns but go out get the
guy [ __ ] start shooting people
they'll lock up all of it not me my true
colors will come out and I'll scream and
run remember when jinny-boy tried to
prank us and they were so scared that we
were gonna get pissed and start I was
like man you really think lowly of me
and bar like you really thought we were
gonna like get out of control and start
fighting you guys and then they [ __ ]
did a sorry job pranking us because I
was just worried for Jenny I was like
man your boss is so mean so what they
ended up doing was Janie wasn't supposed
to go to commercial break his boss came
in and he was like you we lost 5,000
malaysian dollars
I forgot what money they use ring it
ring it yeah or whatever yeah we lost
it's like what are we gonna do about it
and then like I think he was so scared
to confront us and address us that he
just kept focusing on Jenny and they
kept fighting and in me and Bart we're
looking at each other like what a
irresponsible person and I was like you
know what I don't know how they do
things here in Malaysia but Sir this is
very unprofessional yeah I was just
telling this is now right he puts on his
time
he did throw something at him now that
oh yeah we need alright okay this is
gonna get a little violet because he
flew that tissue but it's also hard to
step in because you're like I have heard
of Asian business tactics and this
sounds up that alley so I'm like I'm not
gonna step in and the thing is it wasn't
directed toward us but if they were I
think it would have been a different
story yeah what do you think you'll be
like then I would be like you know what
this is a professional environment and I
think that this calls for lawsuit body
[Laughter]
he just wasn't personal enough it was
all business so I feel like Street Joe
and business Joe are two different
people because if it's just all numbers
and hey I'll you're even thinking about
like do should we just like paint like
paint for this guy I we were doing the
math on our calculator come Bernie
converting ringgit to dollars like you
know it is only a couple thousand
dollars he's like maybe we should just
pay for it cuz like I feel bad that he's
getting in trouble cuz of us you know
and afterwards they're like man we know
you're like that we thought you're gonna
get mad and not like you really thought
we were despicable huh like yeah let's
do this practical joke that piece of
[ __ ] they're gonna get so mad you
thought that Bart was like ready to
attack him but the whole time part is
just kind of like sitting there and like
anyway he's back to this story so the
dude Darren who is talking to the victim
he was sentenced to eight months in jail
suspended for two years in order to do
200 hours of unpaid work he's suspended
like probation it seems like that's what
it is yeah and in the playboy model
they're saying that for her she was
handed a seven months sentence and
suspended for two years so he went to
jail for this stuff and only served one
month is that when she was younger
there's no shoes on Playboy but I don't
know
she looks weathered or what if it says
Rex like whoa is that even the same girl
found the 90s or late eighties early
nineties
whoa okay hold on that's from the 90s
and now she's decided to do a kidnapping
joke on her friends I mean like she's
old as [ __ ] now right
she's like 40-something yeah but she's
using her like heyday pictures yeah the
media is using that she's oldest [ __ ]
playing a prank on a friend like who
does that I'm 40 years old she was
really just that's for real I think she
was trying to be shady and maybe the guy
kind of put her up to it and like come
on honey we can make some money from
this we'll go to Vegas with $8,000 and
spend it all yeah they even ask for that
much eight thousand pounds well is five
thousand and then they raised it to
eight thousand [ __ ] blondes yeah so
we were I know fuck'em welcome she's not
even a real one either did you see that
it was bleached Oh Brady's a blonde
thank you makes sense when they were in
court they were saying that it was
[ __ ] up could be targeted their victim
who is vulnerable they they know they
know her history and they they still
pulled all this [ __ ] on what a nice
friend though her friend got kidnap and
ransom - that's what it's being reported
apparently she had her own experience of
me is she hot - I don't know they don't
know they don't even respect how many
people and moms get kidnapped like it
seems like a common and curt occurrence
like dad was just getting kidnapped all
day
I didn't make a movie about it taking
Liam Neeson I wouldn't I wouldn't put up
that money for you this what because you
know he could pay for it he believed you
hey guys thanks for watching the last
episode did you love it I know you did
but guess what you can also follow us on
our personal social media accounts with
the links in the description box below
so both follow all of us now to watch
more videos check them out
there
[Music]